I'm working in the sagarmatha national
park in Nepal this National Park is
basically contains some of the largest
peaks in the world including Mount
Everest and I am looking at the impact
of tourism on the local livelihoods of
the communities of the Sherpa community
in the region in 1960s almost after a
decade when when this when Mount Everest
was first summited 20 people were the
first tourists who showed up in the
region and that's where that's how it
started in the current situation in
about 2008 there were about 30,000
tourists showing up in this region and
so tourism has progressed or increased
exponentially in the region and it leads
to a significant change in both the
culture the economy the resource
utilization and the chat the pressure on
the physical infrastructure of the
region the tourism is the least
considered to be the least destructive
activity in terms of resource
utilization in a region it has also seen
as a significant livelihood earner for
local community that it transfers a
significant amount of money in the
region but at the same time tourism has
these indirect effects on the region
that are not immediately seen but have
long-term impacts in the area and those
are the those are the issues that I am
grappling with one of the challenges
that tourism has brought in is the
pressure on the resources I would I
would like to say that because of its
incredible economic value people have
benefited significantly but by then by
the pure virtue of the size of the
tourism that is now in present in the
region the resources become really
stressed one of the resource for example
is the water resource and even though
these people
close to pressures the chances that
they're living very close to water is
low
they're usually villages are usually
established close to streams and some of
these streams have dried up so you can
often find in this region's water
pipelines that that run about a
kilometre from from the houses to the
nearest water source and with increased
number of tourists showing up there the
water scarcity is increasing in terms of
fuel this region has a more number of
people require more amount of energy and
that energy requirement it is fulfilled
by either using yak or cow dung or by
burning fuel wood extraction of fuel
wood then leads to degradation of local
forest resource while there have been
efforts made by a community and the park
management in the region to to reduce
that pressure or to manage it it's still
a challenge in terms of physical
infrastructure while the area now has
enough lodges and resource physical
resources to handle about twice the
amount of people that are coming right
now in terms of overall capacity the
challenge is that tourists show up in
this region and a very small window in a
year and so suddenly all the resources
get into extreme pressure for two or
three months and then then they are left
out and there's no use of them but
because of that sudden pressure there's
a physical infrastructure as heavily it
becomes vulnerable the solder master
national park management plan is ending
has ended by in 2012 the new management
plan requires greater method tourism
management understanding into it and my
research directly ties into providing
policy inputs into the sagarmatha
national park management plan
for the next five years I'm for that
reason I am working with the mountain
Institute and the mountain spirit who
were jointly engaged in this research
work and the the policy the the learning
of my research is going to be
disseminated to the local village
committees that have been actually
participating in the development of the
national plan and so the idea is to
empower and also provide a greater
understanding of these drivers of
tourism and create a discussion within
the community so that they can by
themselves come up with certain
understandings that can allow them to
manage what tourism means for them right
from the beginning in my research we
have engaged with local communities
there have been people who have been
directly involved in the research and
have an institutional memory of how we
have conducted the research over the
last three years in this we are trying
because of their continuous engagement
we have kind of locals who are involved
in understanding what are the challenges
that that we have touched on and how we
have come up with a solution so one part
of it is that these local people would
become our represent would become the
knowledge bearers of this research and
the second is that these flow diagrams
that we have developed the beauty of
these flow diagrams is that they don't
depend upon a particular language and
that means that this it is easily
transferable in terms of means of
symbols to to people who don't really
have a formal level of education and
hence for being still being a part of
research and understanding I was a 12
year old kid but when when my father
first sent me to the Indian side of of
Himalayas on a trekking camp and I was
mesmerized by that landscape and so
partly of course I am there's a little
bit of romanticize I mean me too to
follow the landscape but other than that
we have in terms of when I came to Yale
I realized that working in this region
really provides an ability to use the
training of the School of Forestry and
environmental studies of trying to link
and collaborate across these disciplines
and and issues like tourism which which
both have not only an economic impact or
a resource impact but also have cultural
impact they also have they can drive
communities in terms of migration all of
this can be studied in a very
interdisciplinary framework and this
topic becomes a really powerful one to
study it and that that's the most
exciting part of working in this region
where by a simple discipline one cannot
find a simple solution
you